John you're the main character and the
narrator of your new documentary stink
what would you recommend to other
filmmakers and and what can you share
about the process of putting yourself
and your life story essentially into a
film well I think I ended up being in
the film more than I thought I would be
so that kind of happened organically I
thought we'd start off and I'd sort of T
things off with my personal story and
then we would get rolling and I think
maybe my editor actually twisted my arm
or to put me more in there because he
felt it was able to ground the film and
you know was my first film as well and I
had very I had ideas about how it should
be done but it was more based on gut
instinct and then formal training
where's my editor is a filmmaker so we
worked well together because if I was
going off the rails a little bit he'd be
able to tell me you know here's what we
should be thinking after the filming was
done I'm saying like just from an
editorial standpoint right well it
seemed like you would sort of dip your
toe in your story and then pull back a
little bit and then do and I it created
suspense because you weren't quite sure
some of the impetus for the film right
away right and that's that's why the you
know the film starts off with a pair of
pajamas it's like why do these things
smell and I thought that if I use
something the pajamas is a metaphor it
would be less intimidating to people
because sometimes and you start talking
about chemicals it's so abstract it's so
scary but pajamas aren't then we find
out they actually are but the pajamas
again help ground the film because I use
that as a metaphor to traverse the
system both you know where things are
sold the way things are regulated I
think it makes it people less inclined
it's sort of tuned out I hope anyway why
so were there times with your editor did
you sort of then look at what they said
was a he or she he okay and and you know
you're he was right you know maybe I
should do this more but more did you
kind of not battle but would have a
friendly disagreement about yeah I mean
by the time the editor was on it well
you know everything was shot so it
wasn't so much that but it was
definitely you know having a sort of a
hardened pro was good to have as a
sounding board for me because
editorially it's very different you know
I thought that
you know it's sink is not a natural
story in the sense that it doesn't you
know it's just it's not that picture
perfect and so the ending of it was was
tough and it took a long time to edit
because we had to take a lot of
different pieces that people really
hadn't heard about and sort of tie them
together and that that was the real
challenge on and honestly an editorial
okay any unforeseen challenges I know
you have some interesting scenes where
you definitely confront some people in a
very professional manner but any
unforeseen challenges that where it
really tested you and you weren't sure
if you were going to continue well i
think that the interesting thing was
that some people don't want to be
interviewed if you say you're doing a
documentary it's kind of like if you're
in a table if you don't know who the
sucker is in the room it's you you know
so when you call someone and say i would
like to interview you thinking all right
what's the gotcha but i was like very
transparent in one case i interviewed a
senator and i sent her all the questions
in advance just take a look because if
you call like they're busy I get it
they've never heard of you here's all
the questions and asked if I go off
strip just turn the camera off walk out
and they I think they appreciated that
sort of honesty that here's the deal and
then one her political opponent I said
to them would you like to do interview
he said yes but then when i sent the
questions he was like no i don't want to
go on camera and answer these questions
and so that's why i decided that you
know in part of telling the story you
have to hear from all these people you
can't you've seen too many films where
it says you know this person declined to
be interviewed so i called him on Mike
look you're an important part of this
film I'm going to show up and ask you
these questions just to let you know and
here's the questions we're going to ask
you and so that's what I did you know
and I tried to do it in such a way where
they kind of had the heads-up so don't
be surprised if I show up but it's I
think it's important for the story for
people to hear you know because in the
case of stink not to give too much away
but always trying to find out is once
you find out it's completely legal to
sell products with chemicals that cause
cancer and birth defects right you want
to ask the people in power what's the
consumer advantage of that well there is
no consumer advantage but you want to
see how the person's cancer the question
right we always hear like oh don't you
know
send them the questions in advance but
it sounds like it really worked in your
favor because it got people to relax I
think it did and it wasn't for everyone
but it was kind of in those situations
where you know their their handlers be
like well we don't know this guy he
hasn't really done anything you know
this could be like a gotcha situation so
I did it just the show to give him a
little peace of mind and the hopes of
they like all right this guy's just
being honest this is what he's going to
ask and I explicitly said if you're not
comfortable the interview just sign the
release afterwards you know it's just
and I think that work in getting some of
the people that were on the fence right
so maybe not forcing them letting them
kind of ease into it and make a decision
okay we often hear that making a
documentary is much harder than making a
narrative so was there a point though
where you were ready to walk away from
the film at any at any time so at point
it became frustrating because we were
following some of this legislation and
you know some of the stuff was going on
for a year and it's like watching paint
dry you know nothing's really happening
and it's it was being held up by by
design because they didn't want this law
they didn't want there to be a vote and
so we had to and one of the bills still
has is still in limbo so at some point
you have to just you have to close it
you have to come up with a way to end it
because you know this legislation could
nothing could happen for ten years and
so that I wasn't ready to throw in the
towel but at some point I was like I
can't sit around and wait for another
hearing in six months we need to like
you know wind this down interesting I
understand from just a little bit of
research on your background that you're
an entrepreneur or that you were how did
that help in making this film like what
skill sets that you have in having your
own business translated into making a
film and how did you also find them
maybe to your detriment right so in the
90s I had an interactive agency so I was
used to working on projects so I think a
lot of those skills and just a project
doing something from sea de fruit is
transferable to film and you know I
think and then I and then I had a site
that was an Internet auction but for
intellectual property
so I was used to being sued and for
doing the right thing and for you know
saying that we should be transparent and
that whole thing so there are a lot of
like weird things that actually clicked
that word transferable that but you know
I have no formal training and film but I
didn't really look at that as a problem
because I don't think that someone who
had all the film training would have had
necessarily all the other pieces to
bring to the table someone had all those
that that would be great but i hope that
person makes the film but but yeah so
like a lot of this the skills from the
entrepreneurial background definitely
helped so how is running a small
business or even a large company similar
to making a movie uh it's actually very
different I mean the I would say the
common denominator is building a great
team and I think you have to respect
someone professionally but also on a
personal level be able to sit down and
have a coffee with them or a beer and I
think that's really important especially
for startups the thing with with film
it's like you know with the startup
you're you're you know you're working
crazy hours and sometimes for nothing in
the hopes of like a big payoff may be
whereas you know on film you're working
on a project and you're off to the next
one so I think from the the people in
the business it's just a different
animal but you get definitely people in
the sort of the dot-com world and the
film we're just passionate about what
they do and they just love the end
result so that sort of enthusiasm is
pretty awesome you'll meet like some guy
you have to hire like a sound guy in
Washington DC and you know you just
think I just loves it you know and it's
just you find people like that wherever
you go just people you can see that
those people are just really passionate
about it John did you invest any of your
own money in the film was it all your
money how did you start just start small
yeah it's one of those things that I
underestimated the cost of getting it
done but once once you're in deep you
have to finish it you know so it's um
and as you know it's can be an expensive
undertaking but I felt very strongly
about the project and I think that you
know there wasn't really time to put it
on ice and try to get third party
funding without delaying the projects we
just had to
to push through and get it done right
well on a personal note I know that you
talked about your wife's passing Heather
and you show pictures of a family outing
that you and your daughters took her
passing and it was very powerful and it
sounds like that was a big impetus for
the film was that going to the mall and
going to that store that's right um so
after that tricks it sound like it was
really a life-changing experience for
the three of you on when did you decide
to like embark on the documentary well
you know it literally happened and I'm
gonna make this up the the pajamas the I
had been thinking about writing a piece
about this loophole that allow companies
to not disclosed harmful ingredients by
just saying it's a trade secret and I
had a friend who was in film and she
kept telling me you have to do a
documentary you have to do duck been on
that and then I literally the pajamas
were a Christmas present open the
packages at a crazy smell and the first
call it wasn't you know we didn't record
i just call i was like these things safe
and they acted like i was crazy so i
went to the store and found the same
pajamas smelled I mean it had the exact
same things like okay I'm not crazy I'm
like we're going to start recording
these calls I had a friend news the
cameramen who came over we started
recalling and then I'm like oh I think
we have something here just I just want
to find out why these things stink and
that's what happened right and I enjoyed
hearing all the little you know whether
it was voicemail and it sounds so cutesy
and happy with these you know different
companies and things and people
definitely professional but reserved
when they answered questions what can
you advice to other filmmakers on a
technique of filming calls I don't know
what the laws are a senior state but
yeah so you hit the nail on the head it
whether you can record a call varies
from state to state some states or
single party some or dual party dual
party meaning that you have to say if
I'm in New York and you're in California
to say I'm recording this call are you
okay with that and they have to say yes
if it's a single party consent state
then you don't have to tell them because
one party is consenting the person
calling interesting okay so within your
state it's a
a single party well it depends it
literally depends on what state you're
calling from and into but it actually
gets interesting in the individual age
because you could be calling let's say
you think you're calling a call center
in Wisconsin which is single parties
consent I believe that call could
actually routed to a call center in
florida where you need permission from
both parties so you have to hey how's
the weather out in Wisconsin all I'm
actually out in Florida you're like you
know green light so you have to you have
to understand the law because it's it's
important if you get something good and
you can't use it what's the point you
know there's other things to where i was
calling federal agencies and they're
definitely some gray area they I'm
recording this call just say it and then
they don't hang up you know there's
definitely some sensitivities but I
think for things like that I think
there's a you know in advantage of
people having this information so you
know you do the best job you can to make
sure everything is fine because at some
point in time the lawyers have to review
everything and make sure you know
they're comfortable with it well it
seems like with most customer service
calls they always disclose we may be for
training purposes which they seem to
conveniently forget but any times learn
they should have been recording it um so
did you watch other documentaries like
Michael Moore or Kirby dick and people
that do similar things and it's very
powerful just as it is in your film yeah
like I've watched a ton of them just for
fun like over the you I've always been a
fan of documentaries so I've seen I've
seen a lot of them and you know I think
that I guess that helps but it's such a
this is kind of like an esoteric topic
you know and it's it doesn't really make
sense and that's why you know having the
name stink it's like a sense I think
people like what is that you know I
think it's um it's it's it's kind of a
hard story there's so many moving parts
and legislation and regulation and
people it's just not language that
people are typically discussing on a
daily basis that's kind of its kind of
off the radar well just wrapping up here
I just want to ask you it sounds like
you did a lot of research on these
various chemicals how much time did you
spend in the research portion of what
the laws about trade secrets or the
actual chemical compounds beforehand I
mean like a year because the you know
one of the kid having two young kids and
being a single father yeah I remember a
year staying up late and just reading
stuff when they are sleeping really
researching to really understand the
playing field because it was important
to be able to to know who you need
interview and what questions asked you
had to have that foundation interestin
ton of research so and it grew as the
documentary went along yeah yeah but I
think having that that sort of base of
knowledge especially when you're talking
to an expert you know if you're talking
to a scientist you have to be able to
speak their language and sometimes their
answers will be in a language that the
average viewer won't be able to
interpret because you have two aunts ask
them and try to have in layman's terms
so that you know what they're saying is
usable someone could have a great line
and further pH days will get a kick out
of it but if the person watching doesn't
understand it it doesn't really do any
good do you think you gain their respect
by be yeah yeah definitely I mean once
they they start off and they're like
this guy doesn't know anything and then
once you start asking them questions
that you've done your homework I think
that they you know you get good
information because they know that
you're sincere and that you research the
topic and I think it makes the interview
go better